على كل المزيد نورنا في الاستديو وليد
مصطفى الصانع المحتوى اهلا بك يا وليد نور
الصباح العربيه تعد احد اشهر سنه عن محتوى
في مصر كيف ترى المحتوى في العام المقبل
مادام نتحدث عن الموضوع هل هل تطالبون
انتم كمشاهير وصلنا محتوى ان يتغير محتوى
مواقع التواصل
بس لا يعني
كل فتره الحاجه بتتطور والافكار بتزيد
والكريات عند الناس كلها بتزيد فانا شايف
ان الاسكليشن حلو يعني الدنيا ماشيه في
اتجاه كويس
طلعت صورك شايفك اذا كان الصناعيه الفضاء
فانت يعني من مناصري توظيف الذكاء
الاصطناعي في السوشل ميديا مستقبلا عطاء
في الدنيا كلها
رقمي
طيب مصطفى انت عندك مليون ونص مليون
متابعه على مواقع التواصل الله يزيدهم
العام القادم شو الطريقه الخاصه اللي
خليتك تستقبل كل هذا الجمهور على مواقع
التواصل هذا الاهتمام والنجاح والله مش
عايز اكبر المواضيع بس هو احترام احترام
عقلي اللي بيتفرج ان احنا نحاول نقدم له
حاجه تحترم عقله ويحس بها ان هي يعني
تلمسه في شكل في اخر من حياته يعني طب
عندك طريقه خاصه في الكتاب
يا مصطفى
طيب وليد في من احد ابرز الاشياء الذكاء
الاصطناعي راح يعملها بيت 20 ثري انه يحد
من المتنمرين انت في ناس كثير تبعث لك
مثلا انه بتضايق من المحتوى اللي بتعملوا
ما بيعجبها ممكن تتنمر على شكلك
المفروض ان الواحد يبقى عنده ثقه في نفسه
كافيه ما يتاثرش باي حاجه سلبيه حواليه
يعني
والله
فضفضه والحاجات بتاعتي والطلبت مني كثير
جدا فدخلت الاكسبيريا انا احب دائما اجرب
الحاجات الجديده فجربنا والحمد لله طلعنا
يعني
بس هي بالطلب يعني
الفكره
براسك بدك تصلي تدق عليهم
يعني مش لازم اعجبك قوي بس تبقى عارف ان
انا من جوه باحترم بحبك يعني ما عنديش
مشكله طيب المعروف عنك يا مصطفى
على مواقع التواصل انت تختار ها الموضوعات
وعلى
اساسا
في حياتي لان انا الاخ الصغير وعندي اخوات
كبار وعندي اولاد هندسه اشتغلت يعني لان
الحياه جاءت علي شويه ههه
انا بابقى لمستها او احد حكى لي عليها
طيب وليد يعني كمان قرانا المقدمه عنك
وانت تغني ايضا غنى هوايه والاحتراف
يعني عندك حاجه براسك 20 سنه دلوقتي